Russia's President Vladimir Putin has
signed into law the annexation of four
Ukrainian regions a week after
separatist referendums that Kiev and its
allies called a sham but the Kremlin Now
controls less of those regions than it
did to when the votes were held well
here's a look at the areas Russia claims
it has annexed well these are the four
regions that voted in referendums to
join Russia the area in red shows what
Russian forces actually control Moscow
says all of donetskendahansk will be
part of its Federation even though it's
not in full control of these provinces
as her Curson and zapparisha further
south many areas are outside moscow's
control and the Kremlin has yet to
clarify what exactly it's claiming
the Ukrainian Army is carrying out a
pretty fast and Powerful advance in the
south of our country as part of the
current defensive operation dozens of
settlements have already been liberated
from the Russian sham referendum this
week alone in the Curson region the
kharkiv region luhansk and Donetsk
regions all together our Warriors do not
stop and it's only a matter of time
before we oust the occupier from our
land Rory challenge is life for us and
Kevin Rory as we've seen Ukrainian
forces have made some significant
progress in both the North East and the
South can you explain why they've been
able to make such a dent in russian-held
territory
well there are a couple of military
Concepts that can really help us out in
trying to make sense of what's going on
here one of them is culmination and the
other one is initiative now culmination
is when in an attritional fight the
advancing Army gets so exhausted that it
can't push on any more an initiative is
who dictates the terms on the
battlefields the you know the the what's
the where and the how and what we're
looking at here is a Russian army that
basically culminated weeks if not months
ago and has now seeded the initiative uh
to the ukrainians and that's the dynamic
that I think we're seeing uh right now
in in Ukraine on the front lines what
does this mean in real terms well you
know if you look down in the sun region
the Russians are now uh squeezed in the
north on the West Bank of the NEPA River
into a small pocket around Curson City
there they're basically all now within
range of Ukrainian artillery the bridges
over the danipa have been blown so they
can't Retreat there they're essentially
surrounded and that's looking very very
uh unrealistic for the Russians to be
able to hold on that to that in the in
the Northeast we're also seeing the
ukrainians continuing to focus on key
transport hubs towns that are a rail
network basically like is zoom a likely
man and now like svatova and that means
that the Russians and their ability to
keep on fighting this war is getting
very very stressed and that's why
they're losing territory
and more helpers on the way uh U.S
President Joe Biden has pledged another
625 million dollars in military aid to
Ukraine
yeah exactly so we have a continuation
of this Supply that has been so crucial
uh for Ukraine and it's a ability to to
fight off the Russian invasion uh
absolutely Central to that is the high
Mar system this uh very high Precision
mobile
multi uh rocket launcher system
essentially uh so there are more of
those coming there are more of those
Precision Rockets more Precision shells
coming this is all obviously good news
for the ukrainians and bad news for the
Russians is there anything that could
slow down or stop the Ukrainian Advance
well of course there is you know we've
got winter coming the weather is turning
the battlefield is getting more and more
muddy that means that armored vehicles
slow down men slow down
on the other side Russia's mobilization
at some point is going to start hitting
the battlefields on mass those men that
the Russians have been very very short
of in recent weeks and months are going
to start appearing on the front lines
with well whether there'll be any Goods
as Fighters or soldiers that remains to
be seen mobilized men often aren't
particularly motivated or well trained
but yeah certainly the the I think the
ukrainians think that they have a window
of opportunity here and they have to
maximize it as much they can okay Rory
challenge for us and Kiev thank you